il est
19h58 on a on a des news Vous vous
rappelez on en a parlé hier de la
chronique de Guillaume meuriss de France
interre et bien ça y est la directrice
de France interre a fait un communiqué
concernant Guillaume Meuris vous allez
nous dire si ce communiqué vous convient
ou pas ou si vous trouvez qu'il est
léger la question voilà bah vous l'avez
oui ou non est-ce que vous êtes
satisfait du communiqué de la patronne
de France Inter on vaevoir la vidéo de
guillume MERIS ce qui a fait
polémique alors halloween halloween
approche et tout le monde commence à
chercher un déguisement pour faire peur
alors en ce moment il y a le déguisement
éaniaou qui marche pas mal pour faire
peur vous voyez qui c'est une sorte de
nazi mais sans prépu voilà alors il fait
pas peur à il fait pas pe à tout le
monde voilà donc on en a parlé hier hier
apparemment tout le monde voulait des
vous vouliez plutôt des sanctions contre
Guillaume Meurice et la directrice de
France Inter a donc publier un
communiqué hier soir où elle a fait
perdre son malaise après cette chronique
euh je je rejoins le malaise que vous
avez été N nombreux à exprimer une
limite a été franchie non pas celle du
droit qu'il reste à établir mais celle
du respect de la dignité si je suis
garante de la liberté d'expression sur
France Inter je le suis aussi des propos
qui s'y tiennent qualifier n'importe
quel représentant politique de nazi est
une outrance dont le caractère comique
peut-être en temps normal questionné
pour beaucoup une limite a été franchie
non pas celle du droit qu'il reste à
établir mais celle du respect et de la
dignité et on nous a pas pris la phrase
la plus importante ce qui a disé qu'elle
en a parlé à Guillaume MERIS à peu près
dans ce qu'elle dit vous êtes pas
satisfait de cette réponse vous Jacques
cardos pourquoi ben parce que je la
trouve en dessous
en dessous de tout il s'agit d'une d'une
phrase qui peut être alors je sais pas
si elle peut être passible de la loi la
fameuse loi guesso sur l'antisémitisme
mais je trouve que l'analogie est
clairire la blague est de mauvais goût
et il s'agit de quelque chose de grave
dans un moment très grave et je trouve
que sa réponse elle est en de ça elle
est elle est très en de ça et elle ne
place pas en plus la radio publicque à
l'écart des critiques c'estàdire que en
plus je pense que son son rôle est aussi
de montrer d'avoir un geste fort c'est
aussi comme ça qu'on peut mesurer la
neutralité et l'indépendance d'une
direction et là je trouve que son
malaise en réalité traduit quelque part
la pensée peut-être d'un certain nombre
de journalistes ou de d'animateur sur
cette chaîne c'est une accusation qui
vient de façon assez récurrente pas
seulement par moi mais par plein de gens
plein d'interlocuteurs et on voit sur
les sur les réseaux et je trouve qu'elle
est elle est en de ça pour cette raison
elle ne montre pas elle ne marque pas
suffisam
un
un moi je dirais carrément un dégoût
parce que c'est c'est quelque chose de
qui me met très très mal à l'aise cette
cette phrase et voilà c'est c'est pas de
l'humour pour moi il y a de
l'antisémitisme et il est il est pour
moi il est établi il y a aucune sanction
surtout en fait elle c'est beaucoup trop
léger beaucoup trop tienne on a le
sentiment qu'elle le condamne mais en
réalité elle le protège il y a pas de
sanction ça veut dire presqueelle
cautionne cette humour d'ailleurs je
viens de revoir l'extrait il y a quand
même des gens qui rigolent à ça mais qui
sont les gens qui rigolent en fait en
fait ce qu'elle fait moi je pense c'est
elle est elle est très maline elle elle
s'est dit je vais fairebl lui taper
dessus avec un communiqué pour que
derrière on n pas d'amende de l'arcom on
a tout compris on a compris on a compris
quand même la filouie la phrase que vous
évoquez c'est elle la rappelé à l'ordre
c'est ça donc bon ça y est je l'ai déjà
engueulé va prendre une amende de 2
million en plus non seulement non
seulement il y a pas de sanction mais en
plus elle ne dit même pas j'ai été
choqué ou très elle y va franchement
c'est très très très léger on attend
évidemment des sanctions et encore une
fois posez-vous la question si cette
blague avait été faite dans une autre
émission on donne comme exemple celle-ci
mais qu'est-ce qui se serait passé ça
aurait été un un scandale là je trouve
que c'est très très léger et que peu de
gens sofusquent de cette chronique que
j'ai trouvé extrêmement choquante on ne
peut pas traiter un un un dirigeant juif
d'un État juif d'anti enfin de de de de
d'avoir des propos antisémite et le
traité de nazi par les temps qui court
et que ça passe comme ça et qui
reviennent à l'antenne pour moi il faut
le sanctionner et au moins le mettre à
pied Géraldine elle est elle est elle
est non moi je alors moi je comprends
tout ce que vous dites et évidemment
j'ai trouvé que c'était indigne
évidemment j'ai trouvé que c'était pas
drôle évidemment j'ai trouvé que le
contexte était catastrophique mais comme
moi je suis Charlie et que j'accepte
tout Dee je ne peux pas être contre
guaumece même si je trouve que c'est
dégueulasse tu comprends ce que je veux
dire parce que j'imagine que il y a des
Unes de Charlie aussi qui font beaucoup
de mal à à certaines personnes parce que
je sais pas ils vont s'attaquer à à je
sais pas la religion catholique au
prophètes ou j'en sais rien et que moi
je suis Charlie et je veux qu'on puisse
se moquer de tout en France parce que
j'estime que c'est la liberté
d'expression J a un Tex là de Bruno
pomard qui vient d'arriver cet abruti
nous a cassé les pieds sur le kit Expo
se mot qu'on est policier d' association
qui menait des actions en faveur des
enfants voilà c'est pas un copain non
mais je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est
vraiment un vrai
message j'en ai parlé également copus P
char si être Charlie utilise à dire des
saloperies à être antisémite à
être cel c'est la justice c'est la
justice qui
décidera moi j'ai dit que j'étais contre
la suspension comme géraline hier sauf
que là maintenant je voulais pas qu'on
le suspende parce que j'ai même dit hier
France ça ve dire que France Inter
cautionne je veux pas
je pasitp plus et là là je dis que
c'estop léger par quand es directeur
d'une radio et comme France Inter c'est
arrivé dimanche tu peux pas réagir
mercredi en fait tu dois réagir lundi
voire mardi mais tu peux pas réagir
mercredi parce que tu es sous le feu des
critiques et dire après justement comme
un signalement à l'arcom ah bah je vais
lui taper dessus je trouve que c'est un
peu un truc on réagit pour pas que
l'arcom tape dessus je trouve qu'il
fallait réagir lundi ça aurait été bien
de réagir lundi soir trouve de la
sanction de l'arc et elle a elle a été
assez voilà filoutein voilà elle elle a
fait le truc oui moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec Géraldine et c'est la
première chose que j'ai pensé si ça
avait été en dessin c'est-à-dire le truc
le dessin avec une bulle avec marqué une
sorte de naz sans prépus et tout on
aurait regardé cette une et on aurait
dit oh là là quand même franchement
c'est un peu abusé et en dessin ce
serait passé parce que si si si déjà
beaucoup AC un D la bule c'est la note
que je mets à cette vanne ben moi
j'imagine vraiment ça char trouve
aou Charlie c'est un journal
satirique tu sais que tu t'attends êre
choqué radio publque c'est pas une radio
satique guillaumeurce les chér
rappelez-vous ce qu'il a dit sur les
catholiques il a fait des Van très très
très limit aussi très très B et ce qui
est choant d'ailleurs c'est que personne
ne réagit pendant l'ex non plus condam
direct par voilà rig entre eux je sais
ce que c'est
voilà voilà et puis bon Guillaume marice
son son son sa principale qualité n'est
pas
l'humour moi c'est Gill mais oui c'est
vrai vous
ressemble moi je suis scandalisé par ce
qu'ad dit mauris et aussi scandalisé par
le communiqué parce que c'est de la
politique et ça ne prend absolument pas
compte en compte l'émotion et le
scandale que suscite ce qu'a dit muris
et quand vous mettez oui vous dites je
suis Charlie attention là ça peut tomber
sur le coup de la loi a quand même y a
quelqu'un qui me dit quand les Juifs se
cachai pendant la guerre la première
chose qu'on leur demander c'est de
vérifier leur prépus donc il dit cette
vanne que ce que je disais hier
l'émetteur est douteux pardon je je
reviens sur guume l'émetteur est douteux
la vanne n'est pas une vanne parce
qu'effectivement elle rappelle elle
appelle des choses qui sont extrêmement
sombres effectivement quand on quand on
essentialise un juif à son Pr ça
rappelle la Seconde Guerre mondiale ou
pour vérifier dans les écoles notamment
si le petit garçon était juif ou pas on
lui faisait baisser sa culotte et son
pantalon donc c'est absolument
dégueulasse et c'est effrayant et et la
victime devient le nazi le la victime
devient le bourreau donc c'est voilà
tout ça machin mais par ailleurs moi
effectivement comme Géraldine et pour ça
que je disais hier voilà je je suis
Charlie et je veux que ce garçon puisse
dire ce qu'il veut je veux que ce garçon
qui non mais non mais je veux dire que
ce garçon a le droit de dire ce qu'il
veut en revanche je veux que le droit
passe c'està-dire que c'est le droit qui
dira éit non non non c'est c'estarcom
l'arc il do
s'occuper attendons on espè attend
normalement ça pour ça c'est 2 millions
je suis un petit peu calé ENCOM sur la
GR ça normalement c'est de bûches voilà
je vous le dis c'est de bûches ça je
conis toujours plus tolérante pour le
service public que pour les
justement là on doit tenir compte du
fait doivent être ah ben voilà non mais
on est d'accord je veux dire il s'agit
du service public son discours il TR de
ça va coûter de l'argent au contribuable
il va continuer à faire s sur FR à TER
moi c'est pas ce que je
veux tuas plusas plus d'impôt tu rien à
voir c'est juste que France Inter va
devoir réduire
son reste sur France Inter à lui c'est
parce que sa patronne décide de
mainir pas demander plus d'impô parce gu
on voit bien avec ce communiqué qu'ils
ont pas l'intention de le licencier
c'est déjà ça qui est qui est chocant ch
sent bien qu' y a pas de sanction grave
surtout où est le barê des propos
antisémites quels propos antisémites
sont tolérables ou pas c'est veut dire
que parce qu'on est sur France Inter
c'est Guillaume meuce ça passe mais
quelqu'un qui va tenir des propos
antisémite dans la rue ça ne passe pas
c'est c'est débile
ça ça passe si c'est dans la rue ça
passe pas on pas beaucoup entendu le
ministre de la Culture cyil hein moi
là-dessus bah moi là-dessus franchement
ça V pour faut qu'on fasse un truc pour
on puisse l'entendre c'est ça c'est
absolument c'est ce que je voulais dire
bah c'est ce que bah oui mais là
excusez-moi alors euh c'est
communication culture dis je me demande
si c'est pas mieux quand on l'entend pas
si vous voulez hein je je me pose la
question je me demande si si elle est
pas plus utile quand on l'entend pas de
la culture demande sielle est pas
meilleur hein franchement non mais c'est
vrai elle est meilleure quand elle parle
PASF sauf que pour l'arcom quand le
ministre quand la ministre de la Culture
a parlé c'est plus compliqué pour
l'arcom derrière de pas taper fort on
voit bien on a un communiqué faible on
pas de discours
mais nous nous on aa ça déflement elle
aurait parlé elle aurait dit un
truc sur un plateau le brushing c'est
inadm sur France Inter pour le jeis sur
France Inter ce matin c'est
inadmissibleitieuroun
voilonque
[Musique]
s est très courageuse et elle s prend
plein la gueule c'est vraira courageuse
parce que le critère pour moi c'est pas
l'humour le critère par s s ou ou oui
non mais c'est vrai qu'en ce moment elle
est courageuse
désolé est très courageuse a rien à
enlever de tout ce qu'elle dit elle le
fait avec beaucoup de courage mais par
contre bon voilà la ministre de la
Culture je sais jamais son nom mais en
tout cas elle est très sympa elle
s'exprime que
sur
[Musique]
mal voilà RA on l'embrasse la ministre
de la Culture mais pour l'instant on
attend sa réaction à C van sur FR mais
c'est normal qu' est-ce que c'est normal
qu'elle les protège comme ça mais non
mais c'est pas normal du tout mais dans
n'importe quelle démocrat
h la France où tout est verolé à un
certain moment parce que c'est le
service public ça aurait explosé ça je
crois que vous naz s prépus mais mais
Valérie vous m'étonnez quand même c'est
indigne c'est
ind ce sujet tu m'as pas
écoutéanchementuse est-ce que tu m'as vu
là dans C j en disant que guillumétait
un ami des Juifs de
France je ne suis pas un censeur je ne
suis pas un censeur ce qu'il a fait pour
moi est dégueulasse mais je ne suis pas
un censeur ce n'est pas à moi de dire la
loi ce n'est pas à moi de dire oui ou
non il est tu serais patron de France
interre tu ferais quoi je l'Auris je
l'aurais misise à pied ahah
voilà
direct do se déplacer qu' piier quoi
fini non mais tu viens àed à la
radio est-ce qu'elle serait passé avec
un peuple qui a souffert dans le passé
là on dit ça a souffert du nazisme est
non mais est-ce que ce serait passé par
exemple sur l'esclavage ça serait passé
ça serait
pass ça ser pass ser parce que déjà
çarespond non ça correspond pas à son
idéologie son idéologie est quand même
très làdessus fait des fait des V sur qu
moi je l'écoute
jamais que je connais c'est l'hôtel je
vous dire moi je trouve pas ça normal de
toute façon déjà qu'un ministre ou
qu'une
ministre se prononce en fonction des
chaînes en fonction de son ut
direj un
présupposé avant ou après chaque prise
de position déjà là je trouve queil y a
une disparité ensuite moi je redis ce
que j'ai dit hier je trouve que là c'est
on n'est pas dans l'humour je dire on
est dans quelque chose qui est tout
simplement condamnable parce que c'est
insidieux c'est c'est une idée qui qui
va dans le même sens que l'idée de la
France insoumise c'est tout ce qu'on dit
ici depuis un mois mais oui mais bien
sûr mais c'est de ça dont il s'agit mais
tu des de Charli qui déb les gens qui
sont c'est pas la référence alors déjà
moi je fais une différence entre
charliedo et France interre là on parle
de la radio publique il y a un devoir de
neutralité à l'Assemblée nationale
quelqu'un me dit c'est vrai quand la
ministre on l'interroge sur la FP que
voilà il y a eu a eu voilà sur la FP qui
est veut plus qualifier le Hamas de
terrorist extrm dé en ce moment c'est
l'agence France donc c'est du service
publsolument la réponse qu'elle fait
c'est que ce n'est pas le gouvernement
qui fait des articles donc
c'est pas moi qui éc trucs elle dit
c'est elle qui faitur quand il s'agit de
toi en revanche elle a quelque chose à
dire ah bah c'est sûr elle en parle
partout moi mon préféréçon c'est pas
Guillaume Meurice chez les meuriis je
vous le dis voilà c'est son frère que
j'adore
chu pas merci merci on va se retrouver